mais je crois que la jeunesse c'est
mobilisés spontanément parce qu'elle
n'accepte pas cette situation
mais si les lyonnais mais bien sûr les
jeunes de quant à leur manière ont
essayé de réveiller les valeurs qui font
la france parce que la solidarité la
fraternité ça fait partie des valeurs de
la république et ça se vit au quotidien
et c'est ces jeunes lycéens qui ont
manifesté spontanément ne comprennent
pas ce qui se passe parce que ils voient
des copains à eux être expulsé du jour
au lendemain alors qu'ils vivent à leurs
côtés depuis des années sans aucun
problème on leur dit ils sont en
vacances à la toussaint pour l'instant
le combat continue oui bien sûr le
combat le combat continue et pas
seulement à la rentrée des vacances mais
pour plus longtemps parce qu il y aura
une manifestation au yémen anciens qui a
lancé le 5 novembre vont la soutenait
bien sûr bien sûr et si je peux y être
j'y serai je sais pas si je pourrai y
être mais si je peux y at registre